♪
>> Tucker: THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
DIRECTED AGENCIES TO REFER TO
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AS THE
BIDEN-HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME A
PRESIDENT DEMANDED THAT HIS VICE
PRESIDENT GET HALF THE CREDIT?
LET'S SEE, NEVER.
NOT ONCE IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IN FACT, THE OPPOSITE IS ALWAYS
TRUE.
SO, IT RAISES PRETTY DEEP
QUESTIONS LIKE WHO IS RUNNING
THE GOVERNMENT?
WHO IS REALLY IN CHARGE?
AT TIMES IT DOES SEEM LIKE A
THIRD BARACK OBAMA TERM JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO OBAMA HINTED AT
WHAT THIS MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
>> PEOPLE WOULD ASK ME, KNOWING
WHAT YOU KNOW NOW DO YOU WISH
LIKE YOU HAD A THIRD TERM?
AND I USED TO SAY YOU KNOW, IF I
COULD MAKE AN ARRANGEMENT WHERE
I HAD A STAND-IN, A FRONT MAN,
OR FRONT WOMAN AND THEY HAD AN
EAR PIECE IN AND I WAS JUST IN
MY BASEMENT IN MY SWEATS LOOKING
THROUGH THE STUFF AND THAT I
COULD SORT OF DELIVER THE LINES
BUT SOMEBODY ELSE WAS DOING ALL
THE TALKING AND CEREMONY, I
WOULD BE FINE WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: YEAH, KIND OF LIKE A
MARIANNETTE.
SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON AND HE COULD
KIND OF CONTROL EVERYTHING
THROUGH THAT UNKNOWING PERSON?
JUST A DAYDREAM, FANTASY.
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON A FELLOW AT
THE HOOVER INSTITUTION.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
HAVE YOU FOLLOWED THIS STUFF?
YOU ARE A HISTORIAN.
HAS ANY AMERICAN PRESIDENT EVER
DECIDED TO VOLUNTARILY SHARE OF
HALF THE CREDIT?
NO IS THE ANSWER.
WHY IS THIS ONE DOING IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
YOU CAN ALWAYS COUNT ON BARACK
OBAMA TO BE HIS MOST CANDID AND
WORSE CRITIC OF HIMSELF.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS FRAUGHT WITH
IRONY AND KARMA.
WE HAVE GOT TO REMEMBER THIS
SAME MEDIA THAT'S CREATED THIS
CACOON AROUND THE BIDEN
CANDIDACY, THE TRANSITION OF THE
PRESIDENCY INTRODUCED THE WHOLE
IDEA TO US THAT YOU COULD INVOKE
THE 25TH AMENDMENT, REMOVE
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT WAS NINE DAYS AFTER HIS
INAUGURATION WE WERE TOLD HE WAS
NOT -- REMEMBER DR. BANDY LEE
FROM YALE WAS GOING TO SAY HE
WAS A SOCIOPATH AND ROD
ROSENSTEIN, ANDREW McCABE WERE
GOING TO WEAR A WIRE TO CATCH
HIM AS INCOMPETENT AND GET RID
OF HIM THROUGH THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
AND HE EVEN TOOK THE MONTREAL
COGNITIVE ASSESSMENT TEST AND
ACED IT TO SHOW THAT HE WASN'T.
THE THAT SAME MEDIA IS DOING
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THEY ARE SHIELDING US FROM
KNOWLEDGE AND WE HAD IT A LITTLE
BIT A GLIMPSE DURING THE
TRANSITION THAT THERE WERE
COGNITIVE ISSUES WITH JOE BIDEN
BUT SUCH AS IT IS NOW, ABOUT
HALF THE COUNTRY, TUCKER, POLL
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE
IN JOE BIDEN'S COGNITIVE
ABILITIES WHICH BEGS THE
QUESTION WHO IS RUNNING THE
COUNTRY?
AND IS IT JILL BIDEN PLAYING THE
ROLE OF EDITH WILSON IN 1819
WHEN WOODROW WILSON FOR THE LAST
BASICALLY THE LAST 19 MONTHS OF
HIS ADMINISTRATION WAS
STROKE-RIDDEN AND INERT.
IS SHE THE CONDUIT THAT FUNNELS
OUT INFORMATION?
IS IT, AS YOU SAID, IS IT KAMALA
HARRIS AND HER TEAM?
THEY HAVE THIS PSYCHOLOGICAL
PARTICULAR OF REFERRING TO
HERSELF AS PRESIDENT HARRIS OR
THE HARRIS-BIDEN AND THAT IS
SHARED BY JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
OR IS IT SENIOR STATESMAN BARACK
OBAMA WHO CAN'T RESIST ANY
CURRENT EVENT TO WEIGH IN AND
WHO HAS STALKED THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH A LOT OF HIS
FORMER EMPLOYERS.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER BUT IT'S
GETTING A LITTLE SCARE REQUEST
BECAUSE WE JUST HAD A DEBACLE IN
ANCHORAGE WHERE THE CHINESE ATE
OUR LUNCH IN A DIPLOMATIC
TIT-FOR-TAT.
IF THEIR WAY OF THINKING GOING
THE PRESIDENT THE MOST IMPORTANT
SECRETARY IS THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, THE MOST IMPORTANT
AGENCY IN THEIR WAY OF THINKING
IS THE PENTAGON, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CAN'T REMEMBER EITHER
AND TRIPS THREE TIMES, THEY MAY
GET THE WRONG IMPRESSION.
YOU KNOW, THEY DID THAT WITH
JOHN KENNEDY IN '61 IN JUNE.
HE SAID HE GOT BEAT UP BY
KHRUSHCHEV AND 13 MONTHS LATER
WE HAD THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
I'M WORRIED IT'S JUST NOT --
IT'S NOT A MEDIA CYCLE CRUMB
ANYMORE IT'S GEO STRATEGIC AND
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS.
OUR ENEMIES WORRIED OR ANXIOUS
TO KNOW JUST HOW IN CONTROL JOE
BIDEN IS OF THE PRESIDENCY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SUCH A GOOD
POINT.
I FEEL SORRY FOR BIDEN AND I
DON'T WANT TO ATTACK HIM AND I
MEAN THAT BUT IT'S BREATHTAKING
IT'S ALL HAPPENING IN FRONT OF
US AND EVERYONE IS PRETENDING
IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
BUT I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT IT I